you know basically like I'm at a
standstill right shellacky
is to please try harder today their
touristy NHS Dan cj4 jr. is a
california-based
private investigator who runs a one-man
shop in a sparsely furnished office in
the same Orange County Church where he
serves as an usher during Saturday night
services I have a meeting with the ACLU
at 3 o'clock
Ford is devoted to helping people with
little resources who were often
overwhelmed or neglected by the justice
system and for almost a decade who's
committed countless hours to the cause
of exonerating a man on California's
death row who he believes is innocent
but to understand CJ Ford's passion for
righting the wrongs of the criminal
justice system it helps to first
understand CJ Ford's career path I've
always had this tendency to be a little
bit like nosey and I used to watch the
Rockford Files I mean that was my
favorite show
like his TV hero Jim Rockford Ford spent
years tailing cheating spouses and
insurance frauds around Southern
California for little or no money
I guess my business when I first started
off kind of when like the Rockford Files
I'd have class that didn't pay me in you
know and all that kind of stuff like
that but everything changed for Ford
after he got involved investigating the
famous rampart police corruption scandal
in the 90s and a personal brush with the
law changed his outlook forever I
stopped you he said because your windows
are tinted
and I told well you know I bought the
car like this you know but you know just
give me a citation whatever now make
whatever correction is then the police
officer said well I want to look into
your trunk and then right then it hit me
in my head and the rampart the cases I
said this was these guys were telling me
that they get stopped and all of a
sudden they go into their trunk and they
find all these drugs and stuff I
wouldn't let him look at my trunk so
they detained me for over an hour
I told myself after that day that I'm
gonna devote my life into looking into
criminal justice because there there was
something wrong and now Ford is fighting
the most important case of his life and
he believes he's made a crucial
discovery that could free an innocent
man
Kenneth Claire has spent the past three
decades on death row for the alleged
brutal rape and murder of a 25 year old
woman Claire had burglarized the same
house where the murder occurred a few
days earlier which is what led
authorities to him in the first place
but there was something that troubled
Ford about Claire's conviction from the
very beginning
that there was a white boy that was
about five or six years old that saw the
person that committed the crime
he described the person as a white man
the victim was babysitting at the time
of her murder and there was a
five-year-old boy in her care who
witnessed the killing he told police
that the killer was a white man an
account that gained credibility when the
boy demonstrated to the homicide
detective that he could distinguish
between races when shown different
photographs all of a sudden you take the
white man out of the situation and you
go next door and convict a black man
Ford is toiled for almost ten years on
the case but he recently made a
bombshell discovery I couldn't believe
that the DA was sitting on all this
evidence now I'm not testing him so I
found out that they were testing it and
they knew that the DNA didn't match
Claire's they didn't find any
Claire's fingerprints they found someone
else's fingerprints but there's nothing
on the crime scene
that belongs to Claire Ford believes
that the identity of the individual in
this DNA report is the key that unlocks
the entire case and could lead him to an
alternative suspect but the county has
refused to release the name of the DNA
match the Orange County DA's office did
not respond to our interview requests
but referred us to a press release which
says that the DNA evidence is irrelevant
because the victims sexual assault
happened with a vibrator meaning the
fact that male DNA was detected in a
swab of the victims vagina is no
indication that she was raped at the
time of her murder
but Ford believes the county simply
decided to early that they had their man
in Kenneth's glare and ignored
alternative suspects who may match the
DNA on the scene but while it remains
under seal is investing
Asian of those alternative suspects is
majorly obstructed the county's entire
case rests on testimony from Claire's
then-girlfriend Pauline Flores who
claims she saw him on the night of the
murder
was blood on his hand holding a large
turquoise charm that the owner of the
home the victim was watching reported as
missing several weeks after the murder
occurred
the police pressured Flores to wear a
wire or possibly face accessory charges
and they claimed that Claire confessed
to the murder on tape
that's not a confession just like hey
just like leave me alone type of thing
while this might have sounded like a
confession to some jurors the police at
the time didn't think it was strong
enough to stand on its own and wired up
Flores a second time on both tapes clear
repeatedly denies committing the murder
when directly confronted
II need to tell you and I told you
that's another [ __ ] lie and a bigger
problem with the state's case is that
Pauline Flores who's undercover tape and
eyewitness testimony sealed her ex
boyfriend Kenneth Clare's fate in court
has since signed a statement recanting
much of her testimony in this interview
she tells cj4 it that she was still
recovering from a serious accident on
the day of the murder and that the
police may have manipulated her
unreliable memory to fit their timeline
can you remember my own family you know
messed up on my timeline quite a bit so
in other words I was used as a sucker I
believe that if Pauline Flores wasn't
there everything she testified in the
court shouldn't have even been part of
the testimony because she wasn't there
period the Ninth Circuit Court converted
Kenneth Claire's death sentence to life
without parole late last year but sealed
the records and didn't overturn the
conviction now that he's off death row
he's no longer entitled to the same
level of public defense and he won't be
getting a retrial in the absence of
significant new evidence pointing to his
innocence or to another's guilt
Claire's case seems to have stalled but
CJ Ford started an online petition
asking the DA's office to release the
name of the DNA match it attracted more
than a hundred fifty nine thousand
signatures and he's turned it into the
district attorney the DA's office might
ignore him the courts might ignore him
but CJ Ford is prepared to do whatever
it takes to see this case through to the
end
you